Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This work is about using AI to create super
detailed smoke simulations.
Typically, creating a crude simulation doesn't
take very long, but as we increase the resolution,
the execution time and memory consumption
skyrockets.
In the age of AI, it only sounds logical to
try to include some learning algorithms in
this process.
So what if we had an AI-based technique that
would have some sort of understanding of smoke
simulations, take our crude data and add the
fine details to it?
This way, we could obtain a high resolution
smoke simulation without waiting several days
or weeks for the computation.
Now if you are a truly seasoned Fellow Scholar,
you may remember an earlier work by the name
Wavelet Turbulence, which is one of my favorite
papers of all time.
So much so that it got the distinction of
being showcased in the very first Two Minute
Papers episode.
I was a sophomore college student back then
when I've first seen it and was absolutely
shocked by the quality of the results.
That was an experience I'll never forget.
It also won a technical Oscar award and it
is not an overstatement to say that this was
one of the most influential works that made
me realize that research is my true calling.
The link to the first episode is available
in the video description and if you want to
see how embarrassing it is, make sure to check
it out.
It did something similar, but instead of using
AI, it used some heuristics that describe
what is the ratio and distribution of smaller
and bigger vortices in a piece of fluid or
smoke.
Using this information, it could create a
somewhat similar effect, but ultimately, that
technique had an understanding of smoke simulations
in general, but it didn't know anything about
the scene that we have at hand right now.
Another work that is related to this is showing
a bunch of smoke simulation videos to an AI
and teach it to continue these simulations
by itself.
I would place this work as a middle ground
solution, because this work says that we should
take a step back and not try to synthesize
everything from scratch.
Let's create a database of simulations, dice
them up into tiny tiny patches, look at the
same footage in low and high resolutions,
and learn how they relate to each other.
This way, we can hand the neural network some
low resolution footage and it will be able
to make an educated guess as to which high
resolution patch should be the best match
for it.
When we found the right patch, we just switch
the coarse simulation to the most fitting
high-resolution patch in the database.
You might say that in theory, creating such
a Frankenstein smoke simulation sounds like
a dreadful idea.
But have a look at the results, as they are
absolutely brilliant!
And as you can see, it takes a really crude
base simulation and adds so many details to
it, it's truly an incredible achievement.
One neural network is trained to capture similarities
in densities, and one for vorticity.
Using the two neural networks in tandem, we
can take a low resolution fluid flow and synthesize
the fine details on top of it in a way that
is hardly believable.
It also handles boundary conditions, which
means that these details are correctly added
even if our smoke puff hits an object.
This was an issue with Wavelet Turbulence
which had to be addressed with several followup
works.
There are also comparisons against this legendary
algorithm, and as you can see, the new technique
smokes it.
However, it took 9 years to do this.
This is exactly 9 eternities in the world
of research, which is a huge testament to
how powerful the original algorithm was.
It is also really cool to get more and more
messages where I get to know more about you
Fellow Scholars.
I was informed that the series is used in
school classes in Brazil, it is also used
to augment college education, and it is a
great topic for fun family conversations over
dinner.
That's just absolutely fantastic.
Loving the fact that the series is an inspiration
for many of you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!